When did you start learning Korean?
What was the most difficult thing you faced while learning?
It's a long story.
One of my best friends at high school was Korean,...
...and he taught me some Korean words,...
...which I found quite interesting.
After graduating from high school,...
...I decided to take a Korean language course at my college,...
...and I learned it in earnest.
Well, I actually tried to learn other Asian languages,..
...like Chinese and Japanese,...
...but I found Chinese characters too complicated.
And I don't know what happened with Japanese but,...
...at some point, I just lost interest in the Japanese language;...
...maybe too many foreigners already speak Japanese, that's why.
Oh, I remember one of my classmates said...
...he thought Chinese, Japanese, and Korean characters looked the same.
Well, I partially agree with him, because...
...those Chinese characters look almost the same as the Japanese ones.
But Korean letters don't have any resemblance to other Asian languages.
True. In my case, I attempted to learn French once,...
...since speaking French sounds and looks so noble,...
...but couldn't keep it up.
The main reason was that I didn't have a strong connection with French.
I didn't know anyone from France,...
...didn't really have an interest in French culture.
When learning a language you really need to have a great interest in that culture as well.